the choosing three games by Geller is a
very easy task because and I'm not even
showing you my favorite because I
already showed it in this class I showed
it actually in another class and not in
the legend class but one of the other
classes but for those of you who are
interested in seeing it it's super
recommended you will not be disappointed
if you have databases so if you could
see it online look for the game Geller
Annie kya from the Russian championship
I believe it was 1979 this is a
fantastic game were gale of sacrifice
almost the whole set of pieces I mean
just a beautiful beautiful beautiful
game of sacrifices I wish I could just
for if it wasn't recorded that would
have probably shown it to you again but
I don't want to hear comments online why
are you recycling so I'm not showing it
you'll see that I'll show you three
games from three periods of his life one
is from the early period in the 50s then
something in the 70s and the 80s so you
will see that he can play in different
styles it can play efore he can play d4
he was a fantastic theoretician he's
just really really new theory really
understood it and at his time when he
was up and rising and playing back in
the mid to late 40s and then 50 60 70 so
many decades God there were no computers
and there were no books and magazines
like them he is the one who invented it
and that is what's so fantastic about it
he's Sicilian deled white or King's
Indian would black just fantastic stuff
that he created so I chose three of the
games again choosing three is like
asking who do you love more mom or dad
you know it's so many beautiful games
that you love there it's just hard to
pick but maybe you'll enjoy them this is
a game that we played against an
opponent that I didn't recognize his
name I didn't recognize it's irrelevant
because anybody who was playing at that
time he was playing decent players if
he's playing a match between Russia and
England the guy has to know some chess
so d4 Knight of six c4 e6 93 Bishop four
so we have an Enzo Indian at our hand
and he plays again one of the more
aggressive lines Bishop takes pawn takes
c5 okay very well III b6 both sides
playing a playing a very very logical
continuation white is having a very nice
center but he has very very funny pawns
on the C file black wants to take
advantage of it ideally his dream setup
would be to play Bishop a six-night c6
Knight a5 that'll be of course what he
wants to do so Bishop d3 Bishop e7 okay
deviating a little bit from our plan f3
knight c6 92 all this is theory castles
B 498 well some of you might say what
the heck is this move not only do you
allow your opponent to build such a
beautiful Center but on top of that you
are retreating with his night with with
your night well the reason is very
simple if I'm going to get to play the
move Bishop to g5 it's bankruptcy the
whole black position can just go down
the drain you cannot allow white to play
Bishop g5 here that's just not something
you can allow you don't want to play a
move like 8 6 however because that later
on gives me a chance to push my pawns
and up creates a weakness so therefore
there is a simple retreat
okay now Bishop e3 again what I really
like about this game and I've said it
about other games that I've shown in
other classes to my students what I
really like about it that when you
you're done seeing it you have the
feeling that you could maybe have played
a game by yourself because so far I
haven't seen one move that you can say
oh my god I wouldn't I would never have
played that kind of move the move just
makes sense
so pawn to d6 castles again white
continues in a very very logical way not
a 5 Nigeria needless to say that white
is absolutely no interest in working too
hard to defend the pawn on c4 he knows
that it can
so now he played them of rook c8 which
was definitely a big mistake
alternatively he should have played
Queen d7 and after d5 to try to pacify
the bishop on b7 he should have played
f5 that would have been a very
aggressive approach of course the idea
is if it takes f5 he takes d5 very very
interesting very interesting game but
like I said rook c8 was played and again
gainer in this position starts showing
his element he plays d5 needless to say
that if he allows pawn takes pawn on d4
followed by Knight takes e4 with the
rook behind it then it's gonna be a bit
much
the knight is going to get active
threatening the bishop on e3 if the
bishop on e3 moves maybe Knight be to
attacking the Queen and the bishop that
is a little over optimism you know this
we cannot allow that let's not go crazy
but also there's no reason why not to
play this move and when you look at the
highlighted squares you already
understand how this move immediately
reveals that the approxi ate the rook is
now looking very silly the bishop is
pacified and the knight can't even come
back in the meantime Center King side is
just rich of opportunities so geller is
taking full advantage of a mistake so
okay again there are not Isis for some
line that's your one line that will
demonstrate how already late blight
black ears if Queen b7 simply began with
the idea of f5 simply Queen e2 now
everything is under attack Queen a for
trying to hunt for pawns and for Bishop
attacking the pawn and f5 big attack
just a humongous attack this it's
obvious just by looking at the position
you can already tell that who cares
about this pawn look at what's happening
here in a second I'm going to go first
of all I'm threatening Fe but even if
somehow you avoid it and I get to play
f6 this is a total crush again let's
divide the board down the middle let's
say here for example between the E and E
files we see one two three four guys
vacationing somewhere and our guys are
all piled against this imagine if the
night gets to h5 my quickly go to g4
party time on the kingside so after E 5
he tries to close the position of course
his dream is to somehow maintain things
under control so he could somehow play
Bishop h6 take the pawn on f4 he won't
step some position where the Queen comes
here and here like we saw Bishop comes
here and the pawn goes so Geller gives
him no chance for that immediately
breaking at the center beautiful so yeah
what did you again this is this is kind
of a damned if you do and damned if you
don't
in the game he decided not to take it of
course taking bishop takes and already
e5 is coming and I don't think black
really wants to play a move like you
have six does he neither five doesn't
look good
so he tries to contain it by playing
rook g7 and Geller immediately goes
forward already we can see problems now
the idea you can see the arrow is
offering the move f6 and I think that
this is exactly the threat I want to
play simply f6 if Knight takes Bishop g5
and my idea is to play nine h5 and I
don't think that block is going to
survive that onslaught for very long
again very logical play by by white f6 a
sad necessity by now there's nothing
else to do so you might say wait a
minute Yates said necessity but look how
he's defending everything one rupee is
defending the F file there I'm on the
second rank what to do now watch take
like an image of this position and see
how it transforms by Geller really nice
Queen e2 connecting the rocks developing
the Queen making sure that c4 doesn't
get any accident bishop c8 he realizes
that there's just no hope to attack this
pawn h4 again if this seems mysterious
for you it will not be for a while
you'll see
the white is just conducting a one-sided
attack rook b7 rook F to Bishop d7 a4
again let's give black no dreams about
playing the move b5 just in case he was
thinking maybe of playing b5 it's a
moment and then like c4 so for example
let's say if I play rook F 1 then b5
pawn takes c4 Bishop takes Knight takes
and the bishop takes the pawn on d5 this
is counter play that is completely not
necessary one of the things that he was
very strong at his restrainment of the
opponent playing his own game
and on the other hand giving his
opponent no counter chances
so a 497 noticed how clock block is he
is really stuck I mean it's like all
these pieces are interrupting one
another it's like the rook on b7 what
are you doing what are you doing you can
go to b3 but then what's the next move
just no cooperation among the pieces and
yell are very patiently builds and
builds doesn't just coffee house throws
a piece of sacrifices just plays comedy
night here some of you might wonder why
the answer is going to come in about one
second Queenie eight and now the pot on
a four is under attack
Bishop c2 let's not give that one until
we are ready it will happen but let's do
it properly
eight six g4 now we understand the
retreat of the night from g3 he is ready
to send his soldiers up the fort just to
me this is like a textbook way of
attacking and B for opening quiet
opening plays the most aggressive line
builds a strong center capitalizes on a
mistake of rook c8 and now look what
happened king f7 yeah the key guards are
already taking flight White's idea is
very very primitive he wants to go rook
g2 and he wants to play g5 at the proper
moment bring his Knight depending on the
necessity necessity either to g3 h5
h2g for just super so the King runs g5y
not has to take takes the King keeps
running rue cage to the rookies
challenging on h8 again as expected
nothing new Under the Sun here
Knight to d2 again a very smart maneuver
the knight as many possibilities but
watch what he does
the knight protects everything rook b8
again can't blame him for that
rook takes Queen takes King g2 simply he
is first on the file because the rook is
coming to h1 this is the most economical
way to get the file
now watch what's gonna happen with the
pawn on g7 pay attention there Ruka fate
rook h1 and g6 again it takes great just
maturity to understand that despite
blacks ability to defend g7 plenty of
times this is still going to be enough
to win it looks like hey aren't you
closing too many files first the F file
not the G file isn't it too much the
answer is no King the ain't moving away
from any pins
the night is reshuffling rook e8 again
is preparing the ultimate defense Luke
eight seven Queen f8 9 g3 Queenie 7 9 h5
roof 2 g8 Bishop 8 6 98 the ultimate
under I'm attacking your defending
caliph structure beautiful and you think
yourself wow the opponent really
deserves kudos for holding the position
look how he managed to like a puzzle put
all these pieces in a way that they're
defended now you can take on g7 you can
take on f6 what is going on how to
increase the pressure so you think
yourself well let's find something and
the thing is black what's beautiful
about this game you cannot play a move
like g6 with white if you haven't
foreseen this
position and the upcoming continuation
otherwise you will pay g6 you can just
agree to a draw you must have seen he
must have seen the the coming
combination so first of all key again a
move that seems a bit strange the King
just moves to safety
Queen f8 how else to release from all
this and now Bishop d3 protecting the
pawn on c4 making sure that everything
has to go he takes the pawn but already
it's too late I mean ok so another
variation would have been here Bishop
takes g7 takes come on
takes takes and well everything wins
actually you can take on g7 with the
rock you can take on g7 with the knight
doesn't matter this is just totally
winning and Queen g8 is inevitable but
that's one variation just beautiful
so Bishop d3 he goes Bishop takes a 4
like I've said before in some of my
lectures again it's based on the
progress of dying on a full stomach
might as well take the pawn maybe you
can do something because he can do
anything useful so white plays Queen e3
notice how everything was just like
clockwork even a little detail like
Bishop d3 making sure that this pawn was
not going to take me take him only
because we don't want this night to
start hopping around and interrupting
things so Bishop d1 and now comes the
moment of truth because now the knight
and h5 is attack does it have to retreat
if it has to retreat then maybe the
whole attack failed
not with Jenner the decisive sacrifice
90s g7
a beautiful move to make in this
position I'm just totally impressed so
well 96 is coming so he took it Bishop
takes again every time this thing pops
it happens Bishop takes and now let's
analyze the possibilities why didn't he
take back if rook takes Jesus
Queen eight-six pinning the rock the
only move to save it is here and then
takes takes g7 once again that the
passport is worth more than the extra
piece don't wait to defend against that
alternatively if he plays here then
simply here
beautiful move notice that it's just no
move nothing to do my tacking f6 I'm
attacking you seven I'm attacking 87 my
queen can come to 86 just a crush
so he decided to play Queen e8 Bishop
takes pawn check again kind of amounts
to resignation but what can you do here
Queen eight six when resigns no defense
against Queen eight seven and just a
crush a beautiful beautiful game again
Geller was relatively young remember
this is 1954 right 54 yeah I forget
exactly how old he was but I think the
first game that I saw documented on the
database was from 46 so again he's been
playing for like 8 years officially or
in tournaments very impressive ok so
this is one face of Geller and now we
will see another one this time he is
gonna play E for in a Sicilian and I
remember seeing this game maybe one of
the first games I've ever saw in my life
in a Sicilian I was totally impressed by
it very very nice game very methodical
again black didn't play perfectly but
who does when they lose right everybody
that loses means they're made mistakes
he is playing Grandmaster Karen
Gregorian from Armenia then Armenia but
was still part of the USSR so II 4 C 5 9
f3 d6 d4 takes takes Knight f6 Knight to
c3 a6 we have an IDE Orff and gather
both for the knight of Enda stranding
him he would play what seems to be one
of the most quiet variations but what he
makes
out of them is just fantastic Bishop e2
he's six or again the game transposes
interest remaining in us explaining
again and castles knight c6 again Bishop
e7 is also possible Queen c7 and
sometime then I can go to d7 but that's
also possible Bishop e3 Bishop e7 f for
castles Queen e1 in the aforementioned
game that I've told you about that gets
an e Kiev Geller chose another plan that
was two years later than this game and
he played or three years later and he
played a four and again this is one of
the position where you have to make a
decision
black might want to trade here and at
some point play b5 you have to decide
are you going to spend the tempo and
play them of a four to stop b5 once and
for all
I have two black settle for b6 or are
you not going to take the time and just
continue with your initiative he decided
to play here Queen e1 Knight takes d4
Bishop takes d4 b5 again a very very
aggressive line in the variation so gala
plays route 81 nowadays it's kind of
known that the normal line is Queen to
g3 that's if you want to see another
beautiful game in this variation again
by transposition you can see the game
between wayy and who did he play with
black very nice bruise on yeah yeah you
will not see it here but again those of
you are not familiar with it totally
worth it
it's a beautiful King Margie just and
the butts beautiful about that game so
many quiet moves lock down a lot of
material it looks like how you get a
check you don't even check you play this
quiet move the other quite moving the
King can just not escape a make nap so
this variation is with lots of venom
anyways route d1 was played Bishop to b7
attacking the pawn on e4 you could still
go Queen g3 because the mate on g7
prevents it but he decides to play
Bishop aftering okay again remember this
game was played 40 years ago so
no point to be for so up to here we had
a normal Sicilian type of position both
sides building the usual structure one
thing that I have to mention is that
when the bishop is of b7 there's a
bishop on f3 almost always this bishop
needs some defense so usually there's a
queen on c7 here I don't know if the
Queen on c7 will be the best because of
the e5 potential maybe he needs to play
queen c8 or queen b8 queen c8 let's say
that would have been probably more
interesting but after b4 still Gellar
has to prove that he knows what he's
doing
of course he doesn't need a second
invitation he's not even gonna bother
moving his Knight e5 okay so first
things first the bishop is now attacking
the bishop on b7 so he took it attacking
the rock okay rook takes f3 everything
else stays the same and he played F
takes d5 f takes d5 Knight d5 needless
to say that if you were afraid I'm
trying to try not to move the pieces
needless to say that if you play pawn
takes here pawn takes here this is just
gonna be the end of the world you're
gonna lose a pawn and model if you lose
upon what your position is gonna be
really terrible after the capture here
so takes takes Knight d5 and again white
plays a very logical move here he's not
is being attacked should he just trade
it looks like trading is the first thing
to look at because it's a capture but I
think that this would be a really bad
move if you take probably I can just
stick with the Queen mainly because this
bishop doesn't have a good discovered
attack and then of course my queen can
just go back where I can play Bishop c5
and because of that check ID I'm gonna
trade my last piece that's not gonna be
a good idea
he simply plays 94 so you can see that
already two sets of minor pieces have
been traded and the
is definitely invites favor because
black has no counterplay he is not
really attacking anything concrete as
you might see and white has all kinds of
ideas involving this area you can see
that the queen is hungrily looking for
it the rook is already there the bishop
and the night makes sure that everything
here is on the up-and-up from whites
point of view so black played Queen c7
again a questionable move maybe but I
don't know what to suggest
I mean why do always gonna play the move
c3 to just defend this stuff prevent any
anything forever so like rook c8 against
c3 and again I think that black is at
some of it somewhat of a dead end I
think in the long run it's very hard to
fix this position Queen c7 Queen f2 okay
the Queen is improving his position
keeping this rook honest the f7 pawn is
under fire now maybe just rook f1 is
threatened and again how to answer this
noted that this bishop doesn't get to go
to c5 and trade itself for this one like
you would normally want to do this
knight on d5 is a great Knight but
without options of moving so rook c8
hoping that maybe white will get
over-aggressive lucky if white plays
let's say rook the f1 right now Queen
takes c2 and even if you take on f7 I
will just trade Queens of course I will
be very very happy to see the Queen's
off the board if I'm black
yeah needless to say that Geller wasn't
even thinking in that direction no
chance in heck just c3 one little move
solving the problem once and for all
so Queen c6 again hoping for a chance
maybe Geller would miss a tactic but we
know that he won't he wants to play
Knight takes c3 now that's the threat if
Paul takes Queen takes e4 if the knight
takes we get to trade Knights something
that black finds very desirable so
Goeller plays instead Knight to the
other direction Knight f6 check again
this move needs some calculating but I
think that not not really many right I
mean I'm sure all of you can see that
this is
and obvious AK rifice it's not even a
sacrifice when you can't take a
sacrifice it's not really a sacrifice
after pawn takes pawn takes and if you
take again probably I will take with my
rock because I really want to preserve
this bishop
if I am left with this dog from a bishop
with all those Swiss cheese holes on the
dark squares there's not going to be
much relief from blacks point of view so
he has to take I have to say that he
cannot just move obviously he cannot
just move to the corner because then
rook age 3 or Queen h4 didn't solve any
problem whatsoever so he took it took it
and move the rock away again he didn't
want to play g6 because Queen h4 Queen
86 Queen g3 provoking a weakness g6 and
again here Geller plays very accurately
the beautiful thing is that we know
there's nothing much harder than winning
a 1 game right that's what the saying
yes the saying goes and here it's very
easy to kind of lose the head go
directly for jihad you can order your
opponent and give him chances here he
played rook e1 beautiful why because in
this position black is already thinking
of playing the movie file just like in
the game but in the game it was much
less effective if he gets to play the
movie 5-2 things happen the brook opens
up the line opens up and the Queen's
defense by attacking f6 is joining the
defense so you got a really worried
about it if you play Queen to somewhere
ie 5 could be very very annoying so rook
e1 now we have ideas like Queen h4 or
Queen g5 followed by Queen 86 followed
by root cage three well I'm sure it
doesn't take much explaining to see that
black is on the critical list so he took
okay yellow took again notice the
maturity maybe you can play a queen move
but why even mess with that and allow c2
c1 or something crazy to happen we don't
need that he takes and then you don't
have to calculate the element of time is
still in White's favor so E 5 what else
how to stop this maneuver
choice this rook takes rook takes Queen
takes 86 trying to this design to stop
Queen g5 Queen eight six which comes
very very fast but already we can see
that even if somehow there's no mate all
endings are bad because a you've done a
pawn be this pole and this Bishop are
just killing you this Knight is just no
match for them so the rest is for
history here
Queen g3 between age for threatening 87
86 he pushed it of course if King 87 we
simply go it's gonna be transposition
rook age three so he pushed Queen g5
idea Queen eight six just a beautiful
everything just falls into place
King g8 and takes so now he tries the
last trick but of course Geller was
ready for it after Knight takes rook a
score beautiful
why are you wondering what's going on
why did you not take well you better not
take because if you take with the Queen
then he goes I think it's no he trades
and he goes pawn takes rook obviously
because the rook is hanging I forgot
about that for a second if Bishop takes
then you're gonna go Queen b6 check
Queen b1 check and Queen e1 it's white
is getting maded that could have been a
real rude shock but what does he do he
just swings the rook back as if saying
okay so you took my pawn now my bishop
is open how bad can that be for me
the knight of course cannot move because
a ruk h8 mate and I'm just ready to take
it I'm also threatening at some point at
some right point might even threatening
okay check but I don't think I have to
even bother it up I just want my knife
for free so he did this I think that if
he goes rookie 610 Queen h6 just seals
the deal
so he tries this last resort here here
Ruki six Queen eight six check and after
this check
but after King here King here no more
checks not this this was not really
played but here we just resigned again a
masterful game by yell attack you could
see in one game he plays d4 positionally
closes the center channel move to the
King side attacks the King one way here
you could see that from the beginning
again Center King side and looks like
almost like an easy task when you think
black was a grandmaster you're like wow
save for two moves of maybe were very
accurate everything else was kind of
self-explanatory
our last demonstration of this strong
grandmaster comes from the 1982 zonal
tournament and he's playing then I think
he was this was a champion I think he
was either a champion of the year before
he was Russian champion left sockies now
he lives in Israel a strong coach and
Grandmaster very strong and watch this
game this is one of Geller's all-time
best this is a fantastic performance I
mean the first two were impressive this
is just out of this world this is the
kind of game that is not so easy to say
oh I could have done that because it's
not that easy to have done that so d4 d5
c4 e6 93 Bishop e7 again we have a
variation from the Queens gambit
declined 9 f 3 9 f6 Bishop g5 h6 Bishop
h4 castles III b6 so we have a typical
tactic over variation of the yes yes
so we have a typical variation of the
tartar cover defense would be six and
there are several million ways to play
here practically every move has been
played Bishop e2 Bishop d3 Queen c2
Queen b3 rook c1 and the variation that
was played here Bishop takes Bishop
takes pawn takes pawn takes Queen d2
okay b4 is also one of the main lines
trying to design to make c5 a little
more difficult and just to say two or
three words about this variation you can
see that white gave up a pair of bishops
and his idea is saying okay the bishop
rf6 is not a good bishop he's stuck
behind the chain of one that happens in
many lines of the Queen's Gambit and he
just believes that this is going to lead
to a closed position where the Knights
are going to be better than that bishop
that bishop cannot be revived well watch
what happened in this game Queen d2 so
the idea is now that if the bishop goes
to b7 then roof d1 with the idea of
making c5 very very hard to me black is
dying to play c5 so that his bishop will
be alive again
but now the rook the Queen that's why
the Queen run to d2 he took the time
he's delaying his development on the
King side just to stop c5 but again that
comes with a price when black has the
right setup so here he plays after Queen
d2 he plays Bishop d6 a much better
Square for the bishop much better
diagonal on b7 is just looking and here
it just developed very very wisely
so now Sun has played in my opinion very
optimistically okay rook d1 and queen e7
g3 that to me is too much I think that
for better or for worse you should have
just developed his Bishop Castle quickly
yeah black would have gotten the move
c5 very very speedily and equalized but
I still think that maybe black would be
tiny bit better but not enough I don't
think it would be what happened in this
game this is just taking way too much
time when black is already
cancelled and you're gonna have to take
two more moves to develop your Bishop
and castle and in the right of a strong
player watch what he does step one
c5 he is not preparing it
he's not getting ready for it he's just
playing this move right away and he's
telling his opponent okay I challenge
you to do the worst just go for it take
my stuff so he takes his stuff but
that's a very very bad idea of course
the correct continuation here is just to
concede just to grow Bishop g2 knight c6
castles and block will take here and
isolate White's pawn just like his he is
gonna end up with two bishops there are
definitely a little more agile than than
this just one Bishop and denied so block
is to be preferred but again compared to
the game this is heaven so watch what
happened he took on c5 now I don't know
what he was thinking maybe he was
naively thinking that black has no good
continuation because after B takes e5
maybe 95 I I can't tell but Sark his
play I mean but Goeller played BAM rook
d8 what a move in this position my guess
is the sake is there didn't see it or
really underestimated the variation this
is a fantastic move
he took a pawn and he just defends the
second one and again look at the
difference between the Kings and the
development that is the main deciding
factor of our game already white is in
trouble so he decided to keep taking
very optimistic
he could have minimized the damage with
Bishop here pawn takes now listen we can
tell already that white has a worse
position now those hanging pawns are
easily advancing and I have two bishops
to boot everybody wants to be black but
white is gonna get to council he's not
gonna die
he's not gonna just outright I you know
castling when you do this if this your
king is safe so he'll have some
defending to do but maybe you can
survive instead he plays context here
d for again either underestimated or
missed maybe he thought that he would
have to take I don't know what he was
thinking but watch with what force now
Geller places
he already sack two pawns on the Queen
side and it's like almost like a
bughouse game take them whatever I'm
just gonna have more pieces a beautiful
pond sac now you really have to be
careful because you can see that there's
a discovered attack on the file on the
other hand the knight is being attacked
the port on III is being attacked this
is no pleasure so he played Bishop to GT
now let's examine some of the variations
as they're analyzed if you take I just
take it and after here here discover
check and the rook on h1 goes bye-bye
that is very easy he takes for eat XD
for Bishop d5 is the same thing if 92
then Queen b7 look at this beautiful
resource Bishop here takes attacking the
Queen takes and here well for the cost
of one measly pawn I'm attacking the
pawn on a2 twice I can win it at leisure
the King on d1 is going to take him 10
years to try to revive itself to safety
and my bishops and my queen of course
this is just a completely winning
position for black alternatively again
he could have done Knight e4 Bishop d5
the line the Knights are secured and if
you take Queen takes Queen takes d4
Queen takes f3 watch this again this is
another beautiful thing after b7 he
looks like he's winning a rock and after
this come on
okay there are million lines but I can
tell you that this is just winning
totally winning beautiful position the
idea here of course after King takes
rook Bishop f3d taken b7 so he tries to
protect upon f3 so that he can try to
Queen his pawn however I have to this
and you have to let go and black ends up
a piece up just fantastic analysis I
mean if we had 10 hours probably could
do many hours of analysis here in any
event so we saw this and this and he did
Bishop GT so knight c6 again notice that
it's not so easy to play a move like BD
takes c3 because maybe takes takes takes
and then b7 that could be really
embarrassing from black point of view
you have to pay attention to this flat
so 96 developing the peace now b7 is
nothing anymore now he took on e on d4
alternatively if 94t takes d3 Queen
takes again move d1 a self-explanatory
position who wants to be white in this
position it's obvious that there's just
no hope if any of you had this position
against Magnus Carlsen and you didn't
win he should be going home crying just
totally winning so in the game he took
on d4 and again basically sakis is
putting the burden of proof on Geller
he's saying okay I'm gonna keep taking
pawns and let's see how far we can take
him so takes
obviously if takes some a eight then
takes here
Bishop d4 check and Bishop takes on you
lose the roof in the diagonal so he
decided to take here and again when you
look at the position black is up to a
bit white is up to four six seven three
pods already but his King is stuck in
the center but how to win gala does it
in the best way Bishop h3 check you
can't afford to lose your bishop so King
f1 Queen I'm sorry first of all Brooke
takes d4 and about did Queen to e3 they
suggest with the t-shirt have sacrificed
sacrifice the the Queen for the rock but
again it would be a lost position
anyways
instead he plays Queen e3 and again it
looks like not the bishop is under
attack the Queen's are threatened to be
threatened to be traded the rookie is
attacking the rook but yellow just keeps
everything under control
Queen b7 what a beautiful little move
just fantastic moves the Queen away save
his Bishop indirectly now here are the
alternatives in the game he played f3
after rook g1 the only other move to try
to stop the disaster on g7 he simply
takes takes rook d8 when the knight
moves back takes takes takes and check
watch the difference between the two
positions one has a safe king an active
queen and a super active rook the other
one has the rook basically under worst
spot on the board and a queen that's
just not enough to defend the Queen army
3 is a decent piece but cannot defend so
beautiful beautiful lines later on on
the video you can do it you can take
more time and those at home can just
take more time to analyze this properly
so Queen B 7f 3 okay rook takes d1 if
the roof has to be traded let's do it
with a tempo and send the knight to a
were square Knight takes t1 Queen a6
Jack King G one roof d8
notice that there's just no relief he
doesn't give him one moment's rest every
move is a threat every move is a
disaster 9f to Bishop d4 again he was
hoping to get relief now Queen e1 and in
positions like this we know that the
ending is very very soon and he took on
after let's examine the possibilities
here he resigned because if Queen takes
f2 then here that is self-explanatory
but are you block with the queen of the
bishop you lose everything you're on
alternatively after the checkups I'm
Teletubby after the check if he takes
with the king check come on check and
again let's examine the lines king of
one comes a beautiful move Bishop to c8
the bishop is coming to a6 what a
masterpiece the bishop is just all over
started here one here now here yeah and
after here
check check check and mate beautiful
again so another possibility is to block
three three but then of course comes the
move that separates the Queen and the
rock and the King just a phenomenal to
the force by by geller
not everyday do you see a game where you
just sacrifice one pawn he takes you
don't even bother to take back he
defended you just bring the room to
defend the other pawn he takes another
point you advanced that D pawn and again
the price of living the King in the
center even to an experienced Russian
champion like Zacchaeus was just too
much
ok guys any questions about this game
really a shocking game I really
recommend for you to guys see it either
on the database or in the video slowly
when you have time you can check it with
a computer the computer is going to show
you even more lines behind the scenes
but I think it's pretty impressive